Miami's Ocean Drive with its iconic Art
Deco buildings
never really sees an offseason for weeks
now it's been deserted along with the
normally packed beaches and pedestrian
eyes shopping areas of a city in
lockdown the cautious reopening of parks
golf courses and marinas is now underway
though as state officials point to
coronavirus cases showing a slight
downturn Florida's governor Ron de
Santos a close ally of President Trump
says a careful reopening isn't
complicated although on Tuesday the
state recorded its highest total of new
deaths on a single day on Wednesday de
santis announced what he called a safe
smart step-by-step plan to reopen this
new phase will start on Monday May 4th
and will for the time being exclude
miami-dade Broward and Palm Beach
counties these counties have seen the
lion's share of the state's epidemic but
they are trending in a positive
direction
even as beaches and parks reopen in some
parts of the state places like Miami
Dade County continue to take precautions
despite the governor's optimism
reopening isn't a one-size-fits-all
policy over a thousand people have died
of kovat 19 in Florida 1/3 of them here
in miami-dade like many of the states
what this one's facing then is a
patchwork of reopening and a
continuation of restrictions here in
Miami Beach the boardwalks open but the
beach and playgrounds remain off-limits
it's a similar picture in other hard-hit
cities as local authorities weigh the
risks against getting the economy going
again social distancing rules remain in
place when restaurants are allowed to
reopen they will operate at reduced
capacity
Miami's mayor says if people don't
follow guidelines harsher restrictions
will come back if we start to see a
regression if people are not respecting
the rules then obviously we will not
hesitate to start restricting and that's
one of the things that we want to avoid
any version of a new normal will also be
a challenge logistically Miami is a hub
for the distribution of goods throughout
the Americas and restarting trade will
be difficult it's very complicated
it's obviously critical but it's
essential for
to understand what those steps entail
and how people interact with others
while some can now carefully enjoy the
states parks restaurants and beaches
others remain under tight restrictions
the reopening of some parts of the
economy and continued closure of others
is mostly in the hands of local leaders
and their decisions are more crucial
than ever and a Gallacher aljazeera
miami florida